wir sind in der Gemeinde Wandlitz
Ortsteil Klosterfelde Brandenburg hier
leben 3.300 Menschen und wenn es nach
dem Willen des Landkreises Barnim geht
sind es bald 79 mehr in diesem
ehemaligen Verwaltungsgebäude soll das
Übergangswohnheim für geflüchtete
entstehen das vierte in der Gemeinde und
seit Monaten ist die Stimmung vor Ort
deswegen aufgeheizt der Landkreis will
die eskalieren lädt zum Tag der offenen
Tür ins Wohnheim ein jeder soll sich ein
Bild machen können ich bin dafür gefl
üchtete weil
wird unser unsere Pflicht ist den
Menschen zu helfen ich fühle mich
manchmal so ein bisschen entmündigt muss
ich sagen den Bürger geht zur Wahl und
aber letztendlich habe ich kein Einfluss
auf diese Sache ich bin nicht damit
einverstanden erst im eigenen Land für
es gibt keine Lehrer es gibt keine
Erzieher die Schulen reichen nicht aus
zur selben Zeit demonstrieren sie
lautstark vor der geplanten Unterkunft
gegen die Unterbringung der Flüchtlinge
mehr als 1.500 Unterschriften haben sie
hier gesammelt auch der AFD
Landtagsabgeordnete Steffen John nutzt
die Gunst der Stunde Asyl ein Kernthema
seiner Partei Abschottung und Ausweisung
die Forderungen der Applaus lässt nicht
lange auf sich warten ein Dilemma für
den Landrat hier populistische
Meinungsmache dort berechtigte Sorgen
von Bürgern wir kommen ja kaum hinterher
die öffentliche Infrastruktur über
Straßen und Eisenbahn wollen wir jetzt
nicht reden aber Kita und Schule ist ja
wirklich ein etwas was die Menschen zu
Recht mit Sorge erfüllt deshalb ist eine
meiner wesentlichen Forderungen dass wir
mindestens für eine überschaubare Zeit
jetzt sehr viele Entlastungen brauchen
in den vergabeprozessen in den
rechtlichen Regelungen auch die
brandenburgische Ministerin für
Integration ist gekommen ihr ist bewusst
wie fragil die Lage hier und in den
anderen Kommunen ist auch weiß sie wenn
weniger Flüchtlinge kämen wäre die
Überlastung nicht so groß natürlich
wünsche ich mir auch dass in der
Europäischen Union endlich Solidarität
herrscht bei der Aufnahme von
geflüchteten wenn wir die Menschen auf
27 Mitgliedsstaaten gleichmäßig
verteilen würden nach ihrem
Bevölkerungsanteil dann hätten wir
glaube ich wesentlich weniger Probleme
und dass sich einzelne europäische
Mitgliedsstaaten komplett ihrer
Verantwortung verweigern finde ich
höchst kritikwürdig in der Europäischen
Union wurden zu Jahresbeginn über 40%
mehr Erstanträge auf Asyl gestellt als
vor einem Jahr in Deutschland wurden im
vergangenen Jahr insgesamt rund 218.000
Anträge auf Asyl gestellt von Januar bis
April 2023 waren es
110.516 im Vergleichszeitraum 2022 waren
es nur
57.180 also knapp die Hälfte
angesichts dessen will die
Bundesregierung einen härteren asylkurs
fahren
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer will
beim europäischen flüchtlingsgipfel Ende
der Woche das europäische Asylrecht
neuregeln sie will ein Asyl
Schnellverfahren schon an den
EU-Außengrenzen das entscheidet wer
weiter darf und wer nicht es ist ein
historischer Zeitpunkt wir können es uns
nicht leisten dass das Wiedereintritt
wie nach 2015/16 das keine gemeinsame
europäische Lösung gefunden wird wir
haben erste Erfolge indem wir die ähm
Identifizierung die Erfassung an der
Außengrenze schon beschlossen haben als
gemeinsame EU und wir wollen weitere
Punkte hinzufügen für ein tatsächliches
gemeinsames Asylsystem und ich möchte
noch mal betonen dass die
Bundesregierung sich für ein
konsequenten Menschenrechtsschutz und
vor allen Dingen rechtsstaatliche und
faire Verfahren an den Außengrenzen
einsetzt auch Sachsens Ministerpräsident
Michael Kretschmer sieht die Lösung für
die Flüchtlingsprobleme in seinen
Kommunen vor allem an den
EU-Außengrenzen Menschen ohne Chance auf
Asyl sollen gar nicht erst nach
Deutschland kommen meinte CDU Vize
wichtig ist dass man alles nutzt was uns
in der Europäischen Union die Kontrolle
bringt wer die Europäische Union betritt
und dass wir auch eine Handlungsmacht
darüber haben wem wollen wir Schutz
geben und wem nicht und deswegen ist es
richtig dass die Verfahren an der
eu-außengrenzende stattfinden müssen
Menschenrechtler Juristen und
Rechtsanwältinnen sind entsetzt mit
welcher Vehemenz Bundesregierung und
Opposition das Recht auf Asyl sowohl auf
europäischer als auch deutscher Ebene
einschränken wollen das Recht auf Schutz
darf nicht abgeschafft werden fordern
sie deshalb in einem offenen Brief an
die Bundesregierung unterschrieben haben
bereits mehr als 700 Juristen und
Rechtsanwältinnen
wir befürchten vor allem massenhafte
Inhaftierung von Schutzsuchenden und wir
befürchten dass sie
keinen sicheren Zugang zu
rechtsstaatlichen Asylverfahren und
Schutzverfahren bekommen und es wird
sich zeigen so wie bisher das die
Hochrüstung an den Grenzen
nicht dazu führt dass Fluchtursachen
Fluchtgründe in irgendeiner Weise
beseitigt werden oder angegangen werden
stattdessen wird ausschließlich auf
Abwehr und aus unserer Sicht wirklich
ein dramatische rechts Beschneidung der
Schutzsuchenden zum Programm gemacht
tatsächlich ist von Rechtsstaatlichkeit
an den Außengrenzen der Europäischen
Union nicht viel zu sehen mit aller
Härte geht die europäische Grenzagentur
Frontex schon jetzt gegen illegale
Einwanderung vor allein 2023 starben
bislang über 1.000 Menschen beim Versuch
die EU über das Mittelmeer zu erreichen
die die es nach Europa schaffen machen
sich häufig auf nach Deutschland und so
nimmt der Druck auch an den EU
Binnengrenzen zu wir sind im
Dreiländereck Deutschland Polen
Tschechien unterwegs die Bundespolizei
verschärft hier ihre Kontrollen dieser
kleinen Transporter wird von der Polizei
entdeckt an Bord 17 illegale Migranten
aus Syrien auf der Flucht vor den
Beamten lenkt der 30-Jährige syrische
Schleuser den Wagen versehentlich in die
Spree
ist schon was besonderes gerade schon
die Masse der Migranten die hinten
wieder drinne saßen ungesichert in dem
Transporter und dann natürlich mit
Unfall das ist immer tragisch für alle
Beteiligten es sind hauptsächlich
Afghanen Syrer und Türken die sich durch
den Schengen Raum durch bis an Sachsens
grüne Grenze schlagen ausgesetzt vom
Schleuser
der Film die Leute wie sie über die
Brücke gehen und dann ist es ein Zeichen
dass in Deutschland sind und
dafür bekommt halt sein Gehalt also sein
am Morgen kam genau über diese
Bahngleise neun Afghanen nun warten sie
in der Dienststelle Hirschfelde wie es
weitergeht einer nach dem anderen wird
erkennungsdienstlich erfasst Foto
Fingerabdrücke Überprüfung ob er bereits
Asyl gestellt hat oder auf einer
Fahndungsliste steht maximal 48 Stunden
dürfen die Männer nun hier bleiben
in den meisten Fällen stellen die ein
Schutz versuchen die afghanischen
Migranten in diesem Fall wahrscheinlich
auch und wenn das dann der Fall ist
werden die einen eine
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung weitergeschickt
dies ist so eine Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung
Eisenhüttenstadt in Brandenburg der
26-Jährige assemi aus Kabul ist vor zehn
Tagen hier angekommen er hatte
Fotografie studiert die Taliban hatten
seine Hochschule geschlossen die
Studenten bedroht
wenn es möglich ist würde ich gerne
weiter Fotografie studieren arbeiten und
dann sehe ich auch meine Zukunft in
Deutschland ich wäre gern Teil der
Gesellschaft hier
[Musik]
von hier aus werden diejenigen mit
Aufenthaltsberechtigung auf die Kommunen
verteilt derzeit gibt es zwar noch freie
Betten in der Einrichtung aber auf die
steigenden Flüchtlingszahlen müssen sie
sich auch hier vorbereiten 500 weitere
Plätze sollen bis Oktober geschaffen
werden erklärt uns Leiter Olaf Jansen
auch um die Kommunen zu entlasten diese
Überforderung nimmt natürlich immer
weiter zu und nicht ab und Sie können
noch gar nicht schnell genug dagegen
steuern weil so schnell können Sie gar
nicht Leute einstellen und Schulen um
das besseren Griff zu bekommen deswegen
muss man das Ganze besser steuern es
läuft im Wesentlichen darauf hinaus dass
wir die Kapazität in der
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung ausbauen
die meisten Menschen bleiben hier drei
bis vier Monate bis sie auf die Kommunen
verteilt werden die Dauer könnte
ausgedehnt werden auch das würde
entlasten aber wohl am Ende nicht
reichen um für Entspannung zu sorgen
zurück in Klosterfelde hier geht es um
die Unterbringung von knapp 80
geflüchteten Menschen in Europa um
Millionen eine Lösung die allen gerecht
wird ist kaum zu finden im Kleinen wie
im Großen